ready oh yeah
it will kill the ultimate forged in fire
matchup you are the forest and fire
Champion two Champion blades in a deadly
weapon Showdown it will kill two blades
One champion
you decide the winner forged in fire war
of weapons
[Music]
the vajra mushti my name is Kyle fares
I'm 34 years old I met my wife about a
year and a half ago and she introduced
me to bladesmith I think we actually
forged our own wedding rings
originating in India the vashi mushti is
an edge duffel duster the unique design
features sharpened blades on every side
of the handle making it a specialty
weapon only wielded by well-trained
indian warriors the sharp edges on all
sides provided the user with a wide
range of lethal attacks from deadly
stabs and slashes to devastating punches
a traditional Indian martial art where
the weapon is tied to the fists of
wrestlers has lineage dating back to the
Middle Ages and is still practiced today
by professional wrestlers in India using
non-lethal knuckle dusters
the tabar shispar my name is Mark Steele
Knapp with my middle name steel to me it
means I'm a steel knife maker so I so I
couldn't help but be that and as far as
my last name goes I'm pretty good at
napping too it's a bar Shish bar is an
extremely rare weapon that was used by
Mountain lawyers in India Pakistan and
Afghanistan during the 16 and 1700s the
combination of two deadly weapons the
taboris ax was sharp and lethal while
the shishkar's mace was just as
dangerous using blunt force to take down
opponents the mace could also contain up
to eight flanges that were able to
penetrate Shields and Bash through armor
making this brutal weapon a force to be
reckoned with
we're going to make the bajira mushti
I've never made a vajra mushti or
anything close to him so I decided to
use 1084 carbon steel because it's
something I'm more familiar with
I think the most difficult part of the
challenge will be making the handle
something that I'm definitely going to
have to pay a lot of attention to
the two smaller blades are basically the
same one's a little longer than the
other you know and then the other blades
just a big rectangle
five hours into it I feel pretty good
uh one more soap than the forge and then
I'll quench them
I got all the forging out of the way so
I'm feeling good for the handle I'm
gonna go with copper it's moving a lot
better than I thought it was going to
I want to pay really close attention to
detail I want to make a ten thousand
dollar knife today I'm able to remove
three pounds off a five pound chunk of
copper and not got a nice workable piece
tomorrow I'd like to get the handle all
finished up and the blades fitted on
that's basically it
started the day out fitting fitting all
the blades gluing everything up this
thing's sweet
it feels nice too
handles coming out awesome exactly how I
how I pictured it in my head now you
just got to put the finishing touches on
it having my wife pop in now and then
this is definitely a motivation
sweet
I thought it would really make the
handle pop if I can set these four
diamonds in it day four in the books
it's been a lot of fun and uh can't wait
to see this thing go through the testing
and hopefully I come out on top
foreign
I'm making everything half inch bigger
on every Dimension so that if I have to
grind back I still make the minimums I
got a lot of metal to cut 144 pieces
total
I'm making the weapon out of Damascus
because it could be the thing that tips
the judges in my favor the weapon was
made to smash armor and break skulls so
it needs to be strong enough yet light
enough to Be an Effective weapon I got
all the forging done everything forged
into rough shape so far so good the five
pieces have to be consistent so when you
look at that mace everything's perfect
all in a row
in a row I'm feeling pretty good I'm
ahead of schedule
finally done shaping now it's time to
eat treat what could go wrong
all the work so far is coming down to
this step if I don't get this right the
rest of the time will have been for
nothing really
okay accent's going in
I got the heat treating done I couldn't
be happier it's time to start grinding
things to shape so we're cruising
downhill from here
yeah for three days I was thinking
everything is going too darn smooth
something's gonna happen and it did I
found two cracks right now I'm looking
at two options I can try and make this
one work or start over make a new one I
may be able to save this blade I'm going
to cut this out right like this I could
cut around to First crack and grind out
the one on the top I'm not taking any
chances with this I don't want to have
it fail on me so I'm going to give this
thing the toughest test that I could
give it
I think it'll be good
late Spitz welcome to the kill test to
find out what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do I will take your weapon
to deliver multiple lethal blows on this
ballistics dummy
Kyle York first you ready oh yeah
wow
all right Kyle let's talk about your
weapon here I was worried about the
finger Wells that you had there that
they would be an issue especially when
I'm punching no issues there I like the
fact that my acid gets slippery it gave
me a very good grip overall it is a
beautiful piece and your weapon
we'll kill oh yeah Mark you ready let's
see it let's do this
[Music]
Omar it is sharp that chopped right into
the chest cavity breaking a bone this ax
dug in and gutted him your mace
definitely will crush you can see the
breaking bones inside
your weapon will kill
you
all right place this welcome to the
strength test
that's the strength and durability of
your vajra mushties as well as their
overall construction and I'll be
stabbing and punching into this sheet
metal and chain call you up first you
ready for this yep
foreign
test your two long blades held up great
the center blade here took some chipping
on that chain I'm looking at the Grain
in there and it's it's pretty big I
would have liked to have seen that
refined but in general these two blades
held up well nice job awesome thanks bud
all right gentlemen this is the strength
test now to test the strength and
durability of your tabar Shish bars I'll
be using all parts of it to strike this
suit of armor Mark you're up you ready
yes I am let's see it
[Music]
Edge is still perfect
no chips no rolling well the hammer gave
that armor a nice Dent didn't take any
damage
mace is fine the guy inside there was
not happy
all right bleed spits we know your
weapons can heal and we know they are
strong now it's time to find out just
how sharp they are to find out it'll
take your weapons and deliver some stabs
and slices on these spice bags call your
first you ready for this yep let's do
this
[Music]
all right guys let's talk about your
weapon it is comfortable it's a good fit
on my hand it's got a pointy enough tip
over there but with that one piece where
you're missing some edges it was more of
a jagged cut when it came to stabbing
and slashing on both weapons on each end
you'll cut good job thank you Doug Mark
are you ready for this okay
[Music]
thank you
your weapon's nice and light for a
weapon that looks as heavy as this is
you can see that this just went right
through the ribs this is definitely a
cutter good job thank you two blades One
champion you decide the winner forged in
fire war of weapons